[Music]
i had one of the happiest childhoods
until i was seven that's when my father
contracted cerebral malaria
a form of malarial infection that
affects the brain
after having a high fever for about a
week
he developed depression all this while
our family was staying in a really small
town in india
and we had no idea what was going on
with my father
yes we did not understand depression
then
and how it was going to change our lives
today i want to share with you what i
have learned about depression
through my father's journey and my work
in studies
my father seemingly recovered he looked
hail and healthy
but on most days he had a tough time
getting out of bed
and going to work my kind
and loving father stopped smiling
entirely
daily chores including bathing and
eating
became a struggle our family that had
exactly one bread winner
spiraled into financial troubles
but what i remember feeling then is not
so much the financial impact
but the debilitating emotional impact it
had on our family
people around us although
well-intentioned
made things worse family and friends
visited home and gave my mother
unsolicited advice
take him to this priest get him a ring
with that gemstone
many even said that my father looked
just fine and might be
faking being unwell that
enraged me a then teenager
i spent my teenage years grappling to
understand what was going on with my
father
and why his personality had completely
changed
i wanted to do everything everything a
teenager could
to make things better
i started with making cutouts of
newspaper articles on mental health
and saving them neatly into my fire
article by article my interest grew
eventually inspired by my father's
journey i got a phd in neuroscience
i spent years in a lab doing experiments
to understand the origins of anxiety and
depression
later i worked with many organizations
to make people aware of depression's
existence
going by who projections one in four
individuals listening to this talk are
going to be impacted by at least
one episode of depression in their
lifetime
depression is everywhere and depression
is
not a choice what might be the reasons
behind depression
scientists report it could be genetic
vulnerability
or environmental stressors or a
combination of both
having a financial distress a chronic
illness due to another disease
sexual dysfunction obesity a past
traumatic life incident
triggers for depression can go on and on
depression is correlated with having a
variety of chemical imbalances
in our brains about 70 percent
of patients treated for depression start
showing improvement in their symptoms
within four to six weeks of starting
treatment
this number stands to attest that
depression is treatable
but unlike the patients of cardiac
disorders
60 to 80 percent patients of depression
never receive proper treatment why
foremost because of the stigma our
society tags
with having a mental health disorder
people with depression
they are not seen in the same light as
people with having a cardiac disorder
as society we have accepted that a heart
attack could be fatal
so we see quickest medical support to
address it
unfortunately we do not look at
depression in the same manner
untreated depression is one of the
leading causes
of suicides across the world and yet
we do not encourage quickest treatment
or indeed any treatment for it
we can only create change if we make
people
feel comfortable if we let them say
yes i need support
my father had a rare process of
developing depression through cerebral
malaria
he had to be on a lifelong medication
for most individuals depression is not
instant there is often a long trajectory
to it
and in that window lies your power
to support that individual
so when do you know that the person
needs support
what can you do to help the person i'm
going to share a three-step
approach first understand the symptoms
of depression
depression is a health condition it is
not a personal choice
it does include many symptoms as my
father's illness did
loss of appetite or overeating
difficulty sleeping or sleeping a lot
feelings of hopelessness helplessness
and sadness
lack of energy and fatigue
loss of desire to engage in activities
that the person previously
enjoyed and last
having suicidal thoughts
look for these symptoms
step two offer support and encouragement
knowing that it could be a long journey
denying the problem is not going to make
it go away
your loved one is not lazy or
unmotivated
when a person is going through
depression telling them to get on with
life
and just cheer up is not going to take
the problem away
have patience and kindness towards your
loved one
as you encourage them to seek help from
mental health care professionals
recognize that taking care of a person
going through depression
is not an easy task so be gentle on
yourself
as much as you may want you cannot
rescue them from their depression
you cannot fix the problem for them
step three do what you can as a next
generation leader
if you're in a place where you can
change the way workplaces support mental
health
i encourage you to take action towards
it
estimates suggest that major depression
alone has been costing
employees 50 billion dollars per year in
lost productivity
now these numbers are projected when we
did not see current pandemic coming at
us
under the visible pandemic there is an
epidemic of depression that has been
flaring up
i will continue to push boundaries in
the way mental health care is supported
and perceived i'm not asking you to
devote your lifetime towards it
as i have but i do want to
invite you to join me in normalizing the
conversation around mental health
join me in saving those lives before
it's too late
stand up for a quarter of world's
population here
and in case you're wondering about my
father this is my father from last year
when he visited me
he was and continues to be a wonderful
person
and an inspiration for me he leads a
happy
healthy life with the help of medication
if it happened to you or a loved one
i want you to know it does not have to
be a permanent state
depression is treatable provided we get
access to the right resources